[Música]
olá sou carlos limões de esther se fez
ouvir a minha qualificação mais a
qualificação mais importante não foi
falado para vocês é que eu carrego para
o resto da vida e da qual eu me orgulho
muito
eu sou o carlos filho do josé roberto e
da célia casado com a maíra há mais de
25 anos pai do pedro victor mais
conhecido como dj externa e da júlia
gabriela adolescente essa é a minha
família da qual me orgulho ea missão que
deus me deu de criar os meus filhos não
para mim mas para o mundo e eu sou muito
grato a deus por ter a família que eu
tenho
e comércio aqui com uma pergunta pra
todos vocês nós vamos falar um pouquinho
sobre paz e sobre a ong cruzada pela
dignidade da qual sou presidente de
honra também ea pergunta que eu faço pra
vocês que estão aqui e para os que estão
aí assistindo pela internet é você pode
mudar o mundo
quem acredita que pode sinceramente
responder essa pergunta levantando a mão
quem acredita que pode mudar o mundo
levanta a mão quem acredita que não pode
levanta a mão quem não acredita em nada
levanta a mão bem nós temos 60% do
auditório talvez a mesma média aí pela
internet de que acredita que pode mudar
o mundo
no final eu vou voltar com essa pergunta
de novo e falando de paz
hoje nós vamos falar pra vocês um
pouquinho do crime organizado o crime
organizado
que crime organizado tem a ver com um
pais pois nós buscamos a inspiração no
mal no crime que se organiza muito bem
está infiltrado em todas as esferas de
governo na mídia em todo lugar
faz muito barulho e o que acontece com o
bem
o bem não se organiza as pessoas de bem
espero que outros passam por ela mas ela
mesma fica inerte ou faz o trabalho de
forma isolada ou só aquela associação
instituição faz o trabalho não se junta
com o outro e qual foi o pulo do gato
a grande jogada inspirada então no mal
que se organiza bem organizado bem
colocar as pessoas do bem
aquelas instituições pessoas entidades
que trabalham pelo bem pela família pela
paz a trabalhar juntos em sinergia
deixando a inércia tendo atitude e sendo
proativo
diante disso foi criado há um cruzado
pela dignidade justamente com green
pegando essas pessoas esses pensamentos
para que trabalhássemos juntos em prol
da família em prol da paz e muito
interessante trazer pessoas de diversas
religiões de diversas áreas do
conhecimento e pessoas também simples
comuns da comunidade porque cada um tem
uma história cada um tem um pensamento
talvez eu não tenho uma solução para
aquele problema mais um dos parceiros um
dos componentes podem apresentar uma
solução que a gente tem como implementar
ea cruzada pela dignidade começou com
essa ideia com o movimento que depois
virou ao mg e como ela se fortaleceu o
resultado que teve resultado
fomos a campo visitando as famílias que
famílias primeiramente as que vinham ao
poder judiciário que chegavam no poder
judiciário verificava que 90% das
demandas com que eu trabalhava diziam
respeito a desestrutura familiar
então como trabalhar essa desestrutura
familiar a arquivar processo é uma coisa
bastante simples
akiva conflito esse é o grande desafio
não adianta que vai um processo o
conflito continua instalado vai voltar
com o novo processo para a justiça e um
desajuste familiar
então colocamos aqueles voluntários
aquelas pessoas do bem para visitar
essas famílias para fazer a diferença
não levando apenas uma cesta básica
mas levando que matar a fome espiritual
valorizar a aumentar a autoestima
daquela pessoa
conhecendo pelo nome conhecendo quem a
família e quais as necessidades dela e
junto com toda aquela rede que se criou
dentro do município ajudar a promover
aquele ser humano que não é o número é
uma pessoa que tem sentimentos e é isso
fez com que esse movimento ganhasse
raízes e crescesse na nossa cidade está
se expandindo também tudo isso inspirado
no mau é muito simples a gente se
organizar
basta sair da inércia e criamos uma
campanha chamada eu sou do bem eu sou de
deus porque eu sou do bem o sonho de
deus o compromisso que eu tenho com deus
de fazer o bem
o início nós tivemos e temos
três pilares dentro dessa campanha
primeiro delas ser uma boa pessoa fazer
boas ações ser proativo
ou seja ser uma pessoa melhor na
sociedade
ser o melhor pai melhor mãe melhor filme
melhor filha melhor aluno melhor
professor melhor cidadão sendo
efetivamente a mudança que eu preciso
segundo pilar usar as redes sociais para
as ações edificantes como essa que vocês
estão vendo aí pela internet agora
quantos passaram por aqui falando de
experiências boas de mudar o mundo de
coisas boas a gente recebe muita coisa
pela internet pelas redes sociais as que
têm maior número de curtir e
compartilhamento infelizmente são ações
ruins ações do mal
nós temos que inverter essa rota e
mostrar que o bê está aí e que faz a
diferença então dentro dessa campanha o
que é que nós visamos estimular as ações
do bem compartilhar o que for do bem o
que dizer respeito à dignidade humana o
que eleva o ser humano que eleva a
família o que for contra a dignidade que
for contra o ser humano contra a família
não vamos curtir não vamos dá-la que não
vamos compartilhar
vamos inverter a rota e mostrar que o
bem está aí e faz a diferença inspirando
a vida de outras pessoas a trabalhar
pela paz pela família e também colocamos
100 dias de oração 100 dias pode parecer
pouco não é 100 dias de oração mas é 100
dias com s e não com o conselho porque
as ações do bem não tem data para acabar
porém a sua família para fazer a oração
reúne a sua família faz oração
agradecendo primeiramente a deus pela
vida que te deu e pedindo pela paz na
sua cidade no seu estado no seu país e
no mundo formando uma grande corrente
pra que a gente possa transformar vidas
precisávamos de um símbolo da campanha e
pensamos no símbolo da tocha olímpica
a tocha olímpica passou aqui por
anápolis como passou em diversas cidades
e bastante interessante esse símbolo da
tocha olímpica porque é um símbolo que
nos mostra em comum ali olha a tocha
olimpíca passando em anápolis é um
símbolo que congrega esportistas do
mundo todo e é o símbolo da paz
juntando as diversas nacionalidades no
esporte
nós estamos fazendo com que a paz também
seja disseminada e compartilhada
porém a tocha olímpica que estava muito
caro a gente pode até conseguir os
mesmos patrocinadores das olimpíadas mas
nós não queremos ver o nome de deus
associado com o patrocínio
então buscamos um símbolo
vocês vão ver aí a lamparina de diógenes
jorge nunes foi um filósofo grego que na
grécia antiga também a grécia nós
falamos da tocha olímpica tocha vem na
grécia
a lamparina de georges também da grécia
georges um filósofo grego que na grécia
antiga andava com uma lamparina acesa
durante o dia
buscando um homem honesto um homem
verdadeiro
pra quê para que cada um de nós
encontre dentro de si a pessoa nesta
reta prome digna que nós precisamos ter
dentro da sociedade estão com algum
problema técnico
acabou a luz
muito bem
como diz fiat lux ea luz se fez não é
quando nós estávamos no escuro podem
voltar à luz a quando nós estávamos no
escuro a gente sente um pouco de
incômodo
a gente não enxerga horizonte pai vai
dar errado a palestra não é que será que
aconteceu não mas sempre que nós estamos
no escuro a gente sente um pouco de
curso cômodo não enxerga o horizonte não
ver onde a gente pode chegar às trevas
são a ausência da luz
nenhum de nós quer andar nas trevas
então que cada um encontre dentro de si
não só a pessoa nesta reta proíbe digna
mas que faça a sua luz brilhar a luz que
cada um tem que foi confiada por deus
juntando a minha luz com a sua luz com a
dele quando ele com você que está nos
vendo pela internet
nós temos capacidade de iluminar o mundo
e transformar o mundo porque não cabe a
cada um de nós
tudo começa com um pensamento guerra e
paz começam no pensamento no meu no seu
do pensamento nós passamos para a
vontade e da vontade eu passo para a
ação
se eu quero semear a paz
eu tenho que começar a ter pensamentos
de paz terá vontade de trabalhar pela
paz e partir para a ação não adianta ter
o pensamento à vontade na interação não
ter atitude
se eu quero ter uma família é melhor eu
tenho que trabalhar mais pela minha
família eu sempre falo aos meus filhos
que eu dou os meus filhos para ser
melhor que eu se eu não conseguir que
ele seja o melhor que eu estarei falando
em ser melhor que eu não é ter uma
posição melhor que a minha é ser um ser
humano melhor que eu é ser uma pessoa
melhor que eu que faça a diferença na
sociedade como ser humano e não com o
que ganha e sim com o que é com a pessoa
que você tem que ser e não o que você
tem que ter
hoje nós aprendemos a trabalhar numa
sociedade consumista
nós estamos temos que deixar de lado o
consumo e aprender a valorizar quem nós
somos e do aqui algumas dicas para que a
gente possa fazer isso dá-me mais
elogios
elogiar é uma coisa bastante importante
a gente se lembra mais de criticar do
que elogiar
falou se muito implanta hoje vou dar um
exemplo a vocês que não faça em casa
se você tiver uma planta todo dia você
passar por ela e falar que planta feia
não gosto de você você não presta
todos os dias o olhar e falar aquilo foi
uma planta o que é que vai acontecer com
essa planta vai murchar e vai morrer com
as pessoas
acontece a mesma coisa se eu só fico
dizendo você não presta
você é burro você não entende isso você
não vai dar nada na vida
nós estamos fazendo que matando essa
pessoa matando as oportunidades dessa
pessoa
por outro lado se eu começar a elogiar
engrandecer e mostrar as qualidades nós
vamos fazer com que essa pessoa de
frutos e flores se aprenda a elogiar
mais chegando hoje em casa faça isso
muitas vezes a gente fala puxa queimou
arroz tá ruim essa comida mas quantas
vezes durante o ano aquela comida não
esteve boa e você esqueceu de elogiar e
agradecer lembrou só do defeito
nós temos que passar a elogiar mais
dentro dos nossos relacionamentos
perdoou e mais também
agora vou contar pra vocês um exercício
que o professor deu na faculdade de
filosofia chamou seus alunos e disse o
seguinte venham aqui pra aula e tragam
cada um de vocês um saco e também várias
batatas
os alunos fizeram piada vai ter o que é
batata frita tal não faça um compromisso
comigo os alunos fizeram compromisso
ao chegar na sala de aula o professor
disse o seguinte agora pegue as batatas
que estão aí pega uma caneta e escreveu
na batata alguma pessoa que você já mago
o que magoa e que também te magoou
escreva aí e vai colocando dentro do
saco de batata vocês tem 20 minutos para
fazer isso
alguns alunos ficaram com 10 batatas
dentro dos há alguns com 15 alguns com
duas
alguns com oito eo professor diz o
seguinte vocês têm um impacto aqui
comigo então vocês têm que cumprir nos
próximos 20 dias
vocês vão carregar esses atos
aonde quer que vocês vão vocês vão
namorar vai levar um saco de batatas
junto vai jantar vai levar um saco de
batatas junto vai dormir vai levar um
saco de batatas junto vai no banheiro
vai ter que ter um saco de batatas
juntos daqui 26 vão vir para a aula tem
batata não vai abandonar
passados 20 anos ele reuniu aqueles
alunos de novo já tinha tido algumas
aulas antes né com o pessoal com um saco
de batatas mas no 20º dia foi agora nós
vamos eu quero ouvir de vocês como é que
foi essa experiência
alguns deles são o professor foi muito
pesado carregar aquele saco que cansado
que lá era um peso um fardo nas minhas
costas
outro disse o professor pedir demais as
batatas apodreceram eu fiquei incomodado
com aquele as pessoas que passavam por
me sentindo incomodados também que o
professor disse o seguinte pois é cada
um de nós carrega dentro de si vários
sacos de batatas são as mágoas que nós
carregamos e como é que a gente faz para
se ver livre desses sacos de batata
perdoa aprendendo a perdoar primeiro
perdoando a si mesmo e perdoando os
outros não esperando nada em troca
muitas vezes a gente espera que o outro
peça perdão pra gente não a gente tem
que partir para a ação
jogue fora essas batatas que nós e viu
que eu e vocês carregamos aprendendo a
perdoar começa a fazer isso hoje é
difícil pode ser difícil
no mais tudo exige coragem atitude e
prática tenha atitude coloque seus dons
a serviço da humanidade
cada um de nós recebe um dom e se a
gente não utiliza se do a gente se sente
incomodado
coloque esse dom a serviço da humanidade
ele não é para você guardar é pra ajudar
é para servir e pra colocar e eu sempre
digo que a gente quando nasci
deus dá pra gente três presentes o
primeiro a vida
o segundo deles um caderno eo terceiro
uma caneta porque um caderno e uma
caneta porque o caderno para a gente
escrever a história da nossa vida e por
que uma caneta e não max
porque o lápis eu possa pagar a caneta
não o que eu escrevi no meu livro da
vida
eu não tenho como a pagar para eu
aprender com os meus erros e os meus
acertos mas a coisa mais bacana que deus
dá pra cada um de nós é a oportunidade
de virar a página e escrever uma
história mais bonita a cada minuto a
cada hora a cada dia
utilizem essa caneta esse livro que
vocês ganharam pra começar a escrever
uma história diferente uma história mais
bonita acreditem na vida acredita na paz
vocês podem ajudar a transformar o mundo
porque o tempo não espera ninguém ontem
a história o amanhã é incerto hoje é
dádiva seja a mudança que você quer no
mundo não deixe para amanhã o que você
pode fazer hoje
e volto a perguntar a cada um de vocês
aqui quem acredita que pode mudar o
mundo levanta a mão
acho que chegamos a 100 por cento
cada um é um mundo para si mesmo eu
mudando a mim mesmo eu estou mudando o
mundo
e termino aqui com um cumprimento
inspirado lá no lux caiu ok do star wars
que ele dizia que a força esteja com
vocês eu digo o seguinte que a força à
paz e à luz esteja com cada um de vocês
e lança o desafio de serem a mudança que
esse mundo precisa fechou
[Aplausos]